so recently an article that ticked off a
lot of people it's about the ceo
of jpmorgan chase's asset and wealth
management division it's mary callahan
or does who says
you know new people that come to jp
morgan chase rather than working the
traditional 9 to 5 40 hours a week and
we know
it takes 10 000 hours for you to master
a trade
we believe you ought to work six days
12 hour days because instead of
mastering your trade
in five years which is 10 thousand hours
two thousand hours per year
you'll be able to do it in half to ten
which is two and a half years and a lot
of people got upset
that's not healthy why are you making
the new graduates work that way it's not
good
you shouldn't do that and she says no
this is kind of what it takes
if you want to condense keyword time
frames to learn what somebody learns in
five years
in two and a half years some people use
the word you know chunking for this
there's a lot of different words that
you can use for it
but the point is is this a good model i
give you my opinion
for those who are extremely competitive
in a very
competitive marketplace the journalists
who want to get off at three o'clock and
go have their drinks and watch three
netflix episodes at night to think
that's the way of living
want the folks at j.p morgan chase to
not work that hard right
you shouldn't work that hard it's not
healthy for you
it's going to mess with you this whole
thing about hard work is not good for
you
says who says the person that wants to
play it safe is that who the person is
because if that's what you want to say
and i got another person here that's
willing to bust their tail to have their
dreams become a reality
let that person do what they're doing
now let me talk to you about some of the
price you're going to have to pay they
interviewed devon booker who's in the
finals this last year and they say so
devin
what was it like as a kid did you go to
parties
did you do this did you do that devon's
like i don't even remember ever partying
when i was grown
growing up he says here's why he says
that practice in the morning before
school
started i went to school right after
school i had double practice
and then i had another leak i was a part
of by the time i came home and i did my
homework
i had no energy to do nothing i slept he
says i was
chasing a dream a vision to be in the
nba in one day by the way
this story isn't just that story they
interviewed bill gates bill gates says
20 years i never took a vacation
they interviewed mark zuckerberg from
the movie social network he says did you
watch the social network
he says i did want to watch a social
network what'd you think about the movie
how
accurate was it you know what his
comment was he says
we certainly showed a lot more partying
than we did
we didn't party that hard it was hard
work
how's he doing today maybe the most
hated guy in america but the guy is
worth 100 some billion dollars
you're gonna be worth you're gonna be
pretty hated when you're worth 100
billion dollars no matter what you do
know how you make your money i don't
know a certain single person
that's where that kind of money that's
loved by everybody moral the story is
this
a formula i followed years ago is proven
for me you may not like it if you're a
journalist working for new york times
this may upset you but it works for
those
who want to accelerate their speed of
learning
mastery and competing with the big boys
in the industry
it's essentially the great equalizer of
going up against people that have
a lot more experience than you do you
ready it's very simple you may miss it
it's simple number one
out work out improve out
strategize and outlast if you can out
work out improve out strategize outlast
it's going to be very very hard
to compete against you so i did a video
i think two years ago
titled how to go up against the goliath
of your industry if you've never seen
this before you got to watch it
and there's a secret about point number
14 when you're watching know what it is
but if you've not watched it click over
here one of these two guys go
watch the episodes how to face the
goliath of your industry
and if you enjoyed this episode smash
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
you